all right let's talk about this bizarre
change but welcome change over the last
maybe 96 hours in which many Republicans
and some right-wing media figures have
started talking about go get vaccinated
the vaccine is good the vaccine is safe
the vaccine will keep most people alive
not everybody so even though the
headlines has been the headlines have
been Fox News Goes Pro vax Republicans
go provacs people like Marjorie Taylor
green people like Tucker Carlson they've
continued to do the anti-vax stuff but
there is a real question which is why is
this all of a sudden happening there's a
great article in the Atlantic by David
Graham called suddenly conservatives
care about vaccines a number of leaders
on the right suddenly urged their
audiences to get vaccinated in the past
day why now and there is uh there are a
number of different ideas proposed here
and the article goes through Hannity
saying that you've got to take this
seriously uh Steve Ducey saying if you
have a chance get the shot it will save
your life
um Ben Shapiro saying get vaxxed I did
my wife did my parents did Newsmax CEO
Christopher Ruddy saying Joe Biden
should be applauded for making a dent in
the coveted pandemic House minority whip
Steve scalise who has had conspicuously
declined to get a shot announced he
finally did get vaccinated and
um there is a clear shift in tone as
David Graham writes in the Atlantic
article but it's not exactly clear why
it's happening
um one suggestion as reported by CNN's
Caitlin Collins was that there have been
regular high-level conversations between
the White House and Fox News regarding
pandemic and vaccine coverage but Fox
quickly denied that report
another possibility is simply that the
coveted surge fueled by the Delta
variant is making some of these
Republicans realize the hospitals are
getting overloaded we could be looking
at lockdowns being reinstated here as
they are around the world and all of a
sudden when the stock market dropped
precipitously on Monday even though it
more than recovered on Tuesday and
Wednesday Republicans all of a sudden
cared the other real possibility is that
Republicans might be doing the math that
many of you have been doing who write to
me and say David if you have
dramatically higher vaccination rates
among Democrats than among Republicans
could this have an electoral impact in
the sense that Republicans are going to
kill off too many of their own voters
because they are the ones not getting
vaccinated and it will cause them to
lose elections like could it be as
simple as dead people can't vote I don't
know I don't know because even with that
you have the conspiracy of I I got some
emails about this a couple days ago
people writing to me saying David
you people aren't doing a good job of
lying about the vaccine this is this is
the view of a right-wing conspiracy
theorist it's a little too suspicious
that mostly unvaccinated people are
getting sick and dying that must be part
of the conspiracy and it's like no it's
that the vaccines work really well at
preventing death so it makes sense that
it's mostly unvaccinated people that are
getting sick and dying
um a couple of uh uh instances here of
such a pro-vaccine statements from
people we might not expect it from and
then I'm going to get to another
possibility that might explain what's
going on here's Florida Republican
Governor just make it you know known as
covet Jesus to some people a guy who
ignored every guideline early on and
said have full capacity boxing wrestling
everything in Florida here he is making
a lot of sense
um so here's I think the the most
important thing with the data yeah if
you are vaccinated fully vaccinated the
chance of you getting seriously ill or
dying from covid is effectively zero if
you look at the people that are being
admitted to hospitals over 95 percent of
them are either not fully vaccinated or
not vaccinated at all indeed and so
these vaccines are saving lives they are
reducing mortality mortality in nursing
homes since we rolled out the vaccines
in December is down over 95 so a really
really strong pro-vaccine statement and
it could be motivated Again by the fact
that Florida has had a big upsurge and
now represents the one state of Florida
is one out of five coveted cases in the
entire country here is Mitch McConnell
pleading for the vaccine
the Republican governor of Utah said
this weekend that conservative Talking
Heads Are quote literally killing their
supporters um would you speak out
against people who are actually speaking
out what's the vaccine I don't know how
I could be any more clearer than I have
been I've been saying the same thing
about vaccinations all along the way
others can say whatever they choose to
say
but this is something I think I'm a good
example of something I know the answer
to it is not at all unclear that the way
to avoid getting back in the hospital is
to get vaccinated I want to encourage
everybody
to do that and to ignore all of these
other voices so what do you think
explains this what do you think explains
the change you know if it was only Fox
News even though they've denied
conversations with the White House has
there could there have been some promise
of access right this is how stuff works
listen we will give you a Joe Biden Town
Hall
if you guys really help us promote
vaccines that would be completely
plausible the way media works but it's
not just Fox News that's doing it and
also fox has denied conversations with
the White House they may be lying but
let's assume they're telling the truth
is it as simple as Republicans are
realizing that it's disproportionately
their voters that are dying is it simply
motivated by self-preservation I don't
know the answer but I'm curious to hear
from you what do you think explains this
change in tone and remember it's not a
total shift even during these last few
days we've still seen the anti-vax stuff
from some Republican members of Congress
from some on Fox News so it's not a 180
degree change but it is definitely a
change in tone let me know your thoughts
we'll have more about this on our
Instagram which you can find at
davidpackman show find me on Instagram
at david.pakman as well
one of our sponsors is curiositystream
the subscription streaming service that
offers thousands of documentaries from
the world's best filmmakers so yes there
are some documentaries on Netflix Hulu
Amazon but none of those streaming
services give you anything close to the
selection of what you get on curiosity
stream they have all the newest and most
critically acclaimed documentary titles
I'm always finding amazing stuff that I
can't find anywhere else I just actually
watched engineering the future and just
super interesting about we really may be
on the precipice here of a total
paradigm shift in terms of what human
engineering can do and they're always
adding new stuff on curiositystream they
have documentaries on every topic
imaginable I can watch on every device I
own and the best part is that when you
go to curiositystream.com Pacman my
audience gets 25 off that makes it
fifteen dollars for the entire year that
is not a lot of money for the amount of
enjoyment that I know you will get from
Curiosity stream and the link is right
underneath this video